bekannte der aus mein name ist wickie um
meine frage an euch werbe wo ist
fernando
im internet wird sich erzählt dass er
vater geworden und zurück nach kolumbien
gegangen ist stimmt das oder ist es nur
ein gerücht ansonsten liebe größte seit
ich besser vielen dank erstmal dass wir
die besten sind also einigen menschen
ist es aufgefallen nicht sehr vielen was
lustig ist aber auch um die cool dass
wir irgendwie weniger geworden sind aber
wir waren mal zu 70 wir noch zu sechst
ja das ist richtig ihr seht richtig und
wir werden auch zu sechs bleiben
und wir haben uns sozusagen verringert
alles andere
bleibt geheim wir können dazu nichts
sagen zu geleiten